[Music]
inside number nine last gasp so this is
Episode four series one of insight
number nine and the show has been a bit
up and down for me first episode I
thought was fantastic second one I see
what they were going for I had a lot of
issues with them just sort of taking
some very lazy jokes that I didn't
appreciate and third one I thought was
very very good how's the fourth one it's
okay so I'm starting to wonder if like
this is pulling like a reverse Star Trek
movie thing where they the wisdom of the
Star Trek movies used to be basically up
until nemesis that the the even number
ones were the good ones and the odd
number ones were the crap one during
this is pulling the opposite cuz I'm
finding myself really like in the
odd-numbered ones and the even-numbered
ones not so much so last-gasp basic plot
set up you have a family with a daughter
who is ill we don't know with what
precisely it's not really made clear but
she is sick enough to qualify for
basically make-a-wish Foundation I'm
assuming they made up an organization
and I forget what they called it now
but they have this sort of aging pop
star come over to you know wish her a
happy birthday and and and all that and
in the process of blowing up a balloon
he has an aneurysm and dies and when the
father and the sort of security detail
and the woman from the make-a-wish
Foundation knock
thing realize that they literally have
this man's last breath in a balloon
things go from there and basically once
you get as far as that set up how it
plays out is more or less exactly how I
expected it to play out there only one
or two moments that I'm like okay I
didn't see that coming precisely but
then once that happened what followed
that was immediately what I was exactly
my first thought at what would happen
following something like that and I
think the other thing for me is sardines
the first episode really wrote a very
careful line that worked for me in terms
of having a sense of awkwardness without
being flat-out embarrassing very much it
didn't it didn't hit me in that way that
a lot of sort of cringy humor does
because I really I don't enjoy that
stuff and this kind of hit that nerve
and it it's been a little hard trying to
figure out why because strictly speaking
it's not really embarrassment humor
because I mean it's just it's you know
it's these dolls being morons it's not
really an embarrassment humiliation
situation and yet at the same time it
was pinging that part of my brain that
gets uncomfortable around those things I
think it's the inclusion of a kid and
every now and then it flashes back to
the kid and I'm just left thinking oh
god kill me oh and I know and that's
I'm not saying anyone has to have a
reaction that I did I know for some
people that makes it funnier the extreme
inappropriateness of what is going on
and who is happening in front of somehow
makes it funnier I understand that works
for Pete some people it doesn't work for
me not when it involves kids and I know
that this is because I'm a fuddy-duddy
because I am a
and I am kind of disproportionately
protective of children characters as a
result of that I've readily acknowledged
that but it leaves me feeling how I feel
and a bit like a quiet night in I just
feel like once it's in once it's past
this initial setup which is admittedly
kind of an interesting one it's just
really really predictable it ended the
the specific circumstances of what
happened but weren't why I didn't call
but the fundamental basics of what
happened at the very end like I call
that the instant they realized the
potential value of this balloon I knew
exactly how this was gonna end and it
did and it just takes moments and beats
making everybody awful just awful awful
people like all of them the father the
mother you know she's she's not awful in
the same way as some of these other
characters are but she's still awful in
her own way because she was very
obviously looking forward to this pop
star showing up because she wanted to
meet him and the fact that her dog her
dying daughter was gonna meet him was
kind of secondary to her it's I'm not
saying that it's not possible to find
humor in that I just don't and with
something like again to compare it to
sardines that episode even if the the
the awkwardness humour hadn't worked for
me in that that was still structured in
such a way that we were finding out more
about these characters as it moved along
and there was still something of value
to be taking from it even if I wasn't
laughing which I was for tea some part
but here like the jokes are the point
because sometimes you get a story with
jokes other times you get a you get
jokes loosely connected by a story and
this feels more like that so if those
jokes don't land
and a lot of them didn't for me then
you're not you're not left with much and
again the the problem is I I could
basically chart out the whole thing and
I'll get into spoilers on a few specific
things so that's basically it what it
didn't it didn't upset and annoy me the
way that a quiet night in did but it
just left me going feels lazy like I
look at the inventiveness and the
obvious work and thought that went into
sardines or Tom and Jerry and I see this
and I'm like this this doesn't feel like
the same people the same creative spark
just isn't on display here so you know
moving into spoilers some of the
specifics about the one thing that
happened that I didn't call very early
on you know once we were past the
initial setup was that he wasn't quite
dead but as soon as that happened I'm
like they're gonna kill him hey I'm not
entirely sure which one but somebody's
gonna kill him and they did so even when
they caught me off guard with the twist
I immediately figured out from there
exactly what was gonna be the result of
that and I called the fact that the
balloon was gonna be destroyed released
or in some way taken away from these
people by the daughter I called that
basically immediately and that's exactly
how it ended and it's just it might have
worked better for me if sardines and Tom
and Jerry hadn't been so good like if I
had seen this in isolation I might go
okay but like I know that there's so
much better than this and this just
feels lazy in comparison it fells it
feels like they came up with a pretty
inventive starting set up but then what
they did from there is just all the most
obvious choices and it just kind of
leaves me gone yeah so this this is
truly becoming a ping pong series for me
love it don't like it love it don't like
it we'll see if the pattern keeps with
the next one
but until then
last gasp what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all this stuff to
do you know what it is I have a patreon
link and there's links to a bunch of
other stuff as well it's all in the
description check out if you care and
remember folks you are the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]